but you have teeth crushes which I find
so oddly intriguing okay let me explain
I think it might be because I've had
Invisalign twice I had braces for mifold
childhood and my job came back whatever
I know I need to start wearing my
retainers my dog keeps doing them I'll
wear them in the middle of the night and
somehow I'll wake up and they'll be my
dog will be chewing them so it might
sleep I take out my retainer sleep you
make out with my gel formation baby I
mean kind of my dogs great too but what
I'm I just like I love teeth yeah
fascination with teeth I love smiles
it's like the first thing yeah it's
about people is that weird kind of it
was certain like actors too like Julia
Roberts I was think of her love I Julia
Robin I'll yes like all that well deep
that if we showed you some famous teeth
you can maybe I miss the lowdown to her
okay here we go let's see some teeth
here's the first car DB oh yes oh my god
they're symmetrical white anything cardi
does though I love her she can do no
wrong Hilaire have you had her on the
show I have not but we met we were both
performing at this event and we just
have any passing each other and I was
like oh hey cardi and she went I was
like we could be friends just from this
energy moment okay yes what do you think
of somebody oh very nice malone i have a
crush on post Malone oh my god who
doesn't mean I speak it well anything he
does it all where yes I feel like I
sweetest eyes he's very nice yeah very
nice he was very nice that's not hi guys
eldest daughter and she was so nice to
her yeah um how about someone with a
diamond on there too okay see that's
like very good I love Drake subtle dog
yes we we like his teeth as well yeah
yes yeah I just like I just loved it I
would never a very nice but I don't know
if I've ever seen him smart oh he's got
a diamond crack on the TV no now that is
a dog a diamond well then maybe he was
cheeping he's gonna be do that we just
like drill uh I guess I'm not about that
I don't like this the only thing I like
about Dennis is that laughing stuff they
give you
I enrich I am putting a diamond on my
dude right now I'm good yeah um but I
like it it's flashy I like it all right
so what about a gap like Madonna what do
you think about I actually love that I
love them when we when you embrace what
makes you quick feet yeah what makes you
I it's like what I don't get nose jobs
all the sudden like whatever do you but
then you lose your hands like other
people I'm like oh man I know I'm on
support I like yeah well I have a guess
that's why you're you I'm gonna have one
if I don't I wear my retainers I wear
mine that [ __ ] I don't know their
pain is strong anyway Oh
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going